we're going to see the most see sex
links of ink and then and then Keith the
Moose your brown bear and I'm a Tundra
wolf I guess that makes sense yeah
[Music]
welcome to our beautiful Alaska giveaway
it's eight o'clock and already Alaska is
bubbling with excitement it's like he
can't not look majestic I think you
usually don't have man found it right
here we're here in Alaska filming a very
special secret video have more days here
than we have things to do luckily we've
got a game now embarked on foot for our
morning moose hunters cold hard okay
okay we're leaving bye no more chain
link fences will protect us we are going
out into the wild the other three guys
are asleep I did karaoke
[Music]
is where we go for the end of the world
this is like when the character goes
into the forbidden woods Florida man
gets mauled by a moose in Alaska trying
to take a picture of it
[Music]
oh oh that's not tiny sir I don't know
if he sees us oh god he sees us he
definitely sees us now you know I was
very lucky
the rest of the guys
good morning we're in Alaska
this is a game that BuzzFeed made let's
play it an awkward party game by buzz
buzz this is a game called social
sabotage the way it works is one person
draws a we're card like send Amanda and
then the other players have to pick one
of their cards so like you might have to
send a man I've always admired your calf
muscles so this is like hypothetical
texting everyone's different a lot of
these are like posted on your Facebook
or Instagram if the person does it they
get a point boom let's play send a woman
I got it I got it
keep your empty mine so should I send a
woman my breath smells like beef jerky
if I send a woman of video of you in the
bathroom pointing out all the features
or a photo you kissing your own
reflection that is key that was burnt to
a tee
hi
[Music]
I like me can we go see a moose now we
have arrived at the Nature Conservation
Center we're going to see some some
animals
[Music]
so they aren't married it's just sort of
a free-for-all the free-for-all big
salmon orgy reach out for loves well
they just mix all of their seed together
it sounds like your Wednesday date
nights nest is not like my nights Zack
will you quit it everyone can see the
Bears now but I'd like to think that
like bear and me had like a special time
when no one else was there Susan
Sarandon I love your work can I get an
autograph when a bear comes here they
just must crush salmon like this is so
easy there's everywhere yeah and that's
why our brown bear are bigger this is
all very interesting there's a big deer
expensive yeah there are a lot of dough
Rachel till seconds my sill of approval
Eugene there's something I've been
meaning to talk to you about you know
what I'll ask you later
[Applause]
[Music]
yes big fan I love your work
I don't associate with their elk oh dear
that was embarrassing
whale action well I think we're done
here
bye son how many X's do you have Ned I
don't want to talk about this you can
refuse that's not why I use my exes HBO
Go password still what you can't do that
when you're married is that an eagle
it's a ball jump ball do you go Keith
it's beautiful
[Music]
that's like majestic as [ __ ] I just ate
a bunch of oysters rocket roll my old
sister techSpec [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you I
wonder what they're up to right now
Oh Snickers you do not smell good I'm
sorry that I said you smell bad I don't
mean to hurt your feelings
nice no even wild cats act just like
cats
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna break one of those rules
I'll do the inaugural blood
delicious healthy blood queues boys your
favorite part about the blood cube Oh
probably the Cuba yeah female took a
little bit of he got a leg he got a lick
blood pops time to leave now husband
your buddy what's the name before you
buy here
Snickers Snickers my name be porcupine
very created honor rudolph voice chanter
can taste
[Music]
No